[Music]
[Applause]
I'm the vet come sophomore in Yale
College studying computer science and
statistics and data science I'm the
co-president for Yale code for good
which is an undergraduate organization
that seeks to have like student project
teams with local nonprofits and other
community organizations and we also host
a wide range of talks workshops
hackathons in the intersection of like
software development for a social
purpose
I'm Berkeley I'm a junior at Yale
between such and data science and I'm a
project Li for yo steam we have been
cooperating with the digital humanities
up on a wall project including beyond
boundary this whole Center and so what
we are focused on is to explore the
cause founder of STEM education and art
so we have organized quite a lot like
fun activities on campus like playing
around with bubbles or like having like
succulent plants and figure out how a
second influence can fit into both the
biological aspects and and and artistic
aspects of like expressions and we also
have like activity on campus next week
on succulents so funny and if you are
interested feel free to join us next
Friday but today we have a panel of
amazing speakers here each from a
different discipline and we're really
interesting to hear their presentations
and later on after their short
presentations we're going to open up to
the four and see if anyone have any more
questions yeah
and I guess we'll start from oh what's
clearly on hello I'm Tiffany Lee and I'm
a resident fellow at the law schools
information society project and there I
lead an initiative called the Wikimedia
and Yale Law School initiative on
intermediaries and information it's a
very long name for a very simple concept
which is that I conduct research
have events and programming along the
topics of open Internet open knowledge
open access specifically my lot of my
legal research focuses on intermediary
liability or the rules reliability for
platforms tech platforms like Facebook
or Google or Twitter so when I think
about interdisciplinary research or open
knowledge or new ways of thinking about
humanities or the social sciences a lot
of my knowledge is filtered through my
experiences and law is not really what
you may think of as a discipline that is
very open to interdisciplinary research
we don't have any fun projects with
succulents for example I've never seen a
project where you know a law school does
something where you grow a plant or take
care of an animal in order to learn a
principle of law but we do have some new
interdisciplinary work and my research
centre does some of it already so the
information society project does work on
internet and Technology law and policy
and obviously we work a lot with public
policy with history but a lot with
scientific folks as well because the
technology industry obviously is very
heavily technical so we work a lot with
computer science departments with data
science departments with the ice schools
that are popping up all over the nation
right now there's a lot of
interdisciplinary work but specifically
my work is about open Internet and open
access and when I submitted the title
for my provocation for this short talk I
actually meant to write to the power of
open but I type it it to the power I'd
open but I thought about it for a moment
actually I think it makes sense to to
think of it in terms of what sort of
power would we try to open up if we
could as people who have knowledge and
who try to put out knowledge in the
world so from my work we think about
open Internet and threats to open
Internet and open speech online so this
can include something like for example a
government completely shutting down
internet access or shutting down or
censoring different websites as many of
you know for example there's a concept
of what people call the Great Firewall
in China
which is where many websites are blocked
in China often because they allow for
certain news items or certain
information the government doesn't want
people to know but not only that we also
have threats including laws that may be
very well-intentioned but may have
negative consequences for open knowledge
for example we have a number of laws in
the EU right now that are trying to set
specific rules for tech companies
regarding the content that they host
online traditionally we've had this
history of allowing tech companies some
immunity so if they host content that
may be illegal for some reason they may
be immune for legal consequences do you
do some laws that we have in place
however these new laws kind of get rid
of that immunity and this makes it so
that if there's content that is deemed
illegal the company will have to pay a
fine or fix legal consequences and the
ultimate consequence of that is that
these companies just tend to over censor
or block things or filter things out
before they even get posted and that I
think is a negative consequence and
negative not just for tech companies or
Internet users but for the ideas of
having open free speech online and
having open knowledge and open access
for information got nothing else what I
research is really how can we further
those goals how can we further open
expression free speech and the idea of
the lofty idea of having democratic
values that are fueled by people who
have knowledge and are able to share
knowledge so that's specifically what
I'm working on but I'm also really
interested in knowing how the rest of
you and everyone here is able to kind of
push those boundaries forward and bring
knowledge either to an open space or to
the public or to include people who may
not normally be including the
conversation I think those are what
really interests me and the themes of
today's symposium thank you
[Applause]
thank you our next speaker we'd like to
introduce is our Alice Kaplan and
Kristoff Shoei from the French
Department they'll be presenting on
mapping post-war networks and an index
for combat in 1944 to 1947 Alice Kaplan
will join us eventually she has been
delayed by tasks from being a chair
so our thank you so I think it's quite
timely to have a provocative roundtable
here about digital many days considering
what's going on in the Chronicle of
Higher Education right now so whether it
is a network map a digital edition or a
database digital humanities are
meaningful when they renew the way we
perceive our objects and this is what we
are trying to do in the combat project
use computer to analyze a famous
newspaper that is simply too big for one
brain the goal is to challenge received
ideas about networks and newspapers in
post-war France so exploring khumba we
are focusing on signed and unsigned
articles published in a French daily
newspaper khumba from 1944 to 1947 so
that's four year worth of data this is a
first step in a larger project called
mapping post-war networks so what was
khumba and why is it worth mapping
briefly
Kumba was the most innovative and most
admired daily newspaper in post-war
France it begins as an underground
resistance newspaper and at deliberation
the editors Albert Camus and Pascal Pia
assembled a group of young
forward-thinking writers an intellectual
who reported nationally and
internationally on politics and culture
the paper nourished two carriers of many
important writers and thinkers and set a
high standard among all the post-war
newspapers for its style and
intellectual emissions so because of the
very form of this
Media and the complexity of the époque
historian of the post-war era have
mainly studied individual intellectual
trajectories the individual carriers of
camera of Sark Beauvoir have been
tracked down on a nearly daily basis
while group biographies such as Sarah
Beck well lively existentialist cafe
have woven their intellectual lives
together but because of the way this is
shaped they everything was done on a
kind of one-to-one history right our
combat index gives us the opportunity to
look at the same period from a radically
new angle rather than focusing on star
individual across the issues of combat
we explore the networks of Rider to
understand who wrote for combat and how
the newspaper evolved over time in order
to get a different picture of the
post-war France Network post-war France
is a period preoccupied with two
ideological models communism and
American capitalism and it is not all
clear how combined navigated these
waters when it veered left when right it
particular in particular there is a lot
of debate about to what extent khumba
was influenced by the goal the leading
figure of the resistance and some
historians think it became go lists very
quickly and other insist it resisted by
exploring the newspaper through a
network map we would like to reshape
this debate by better understanding the
dynamics going on so the project started
with PDFs and thanks to support from
Yale's Digital humanity lab we are
working with a searchable PDF of a full
collection of khumba obtained from the
French national library and already
working with a full-text searchable PDF
is already doing digital humanities and
it's already changing the way we can
work with this source right so from this
base we began to build an index manually
it includes categories that are
objective enough to be relevant for a
network graph and rich enough to allow
us to analyze the data from many angles
so here you can find some of the
categories we are indexing so the
technology decides on what we are doing
right the question we are asking and our
perspective on our objects for the
and for the worst to challenge for
instance the first challenge is that
obviously a spreadsheet like this does
violence to historical complexity it
might seem relatively easy to determine
the nationality of a writer but let's
consider the case of Jo Malachy for
instance Malachy born in Poland
stateless in France
finally naturalized American write in
French and Warner French literary prize
he publishes an article in khumba
explaining American literature to the
French and it's even harder to
generalize about the political affinity
of the other in a period where the wrong
politics could send you to a firing
squad and where the political affinities
which so often between 1944 and 1946
there were rider who slide from fascism
to communism to anti-communism so what
we are trying to do in these cases is to
think from the end to consider the goal
of our analysis what set of question do
we want to ask to this data what would
it be more relevant to characterize
malachy as polish French or American
depending on that
well Medicare returning to France
described in khumba as a French writer
with an expertise in American literature
will be character categorized sorry as
French another challenge is obviously
collecting the data and in our case the
more data we have good data at least the
more pattern we can see and the data
entry has been slow heroic even and we
we're really grateful to our
collaborator Robin brown and you know
sociopath Idahoan while it Busha coo for
their contribution but in the next phase
of the project we had to find more money
to be able to digitize to a higher
company to digitize nearly 3,000 pages
of combat so that's more than 50,000
articles that will be then available for
analyzes we will then be able to see
this period from a whole new perspective
who participated in this newspaper
collaborated and then and now as a
flagship in celebrated then and now as a
flagship of French freedom what
information did the khumba
gather and where did it come from so I'm
saying we will be able to do that and
this is maybe my provocative point just
by digitizing this just by building a
network map digital mapping will not
provide us with answers because digital
humanities never do they help answering
a question the goal of this network
visualization will be to provide us the
researchers with an interface to delve
into those three years of combat it will
allow us to read those three years of
combat from a very different angle
signaling unexpected connections
phenomenons that would have never been
possible to to see into the text reading
combat in the normal way and that will
ultimately invite us to dig into new
cases with a whole new set of question
and this is maybe true this interface
that we can do justice to an
extraordinary period of the French
cultural history and to make visible
this remark by Simone de Beauvoir in her
postwar memoir and i quote to be 20 or
25 in september of 54 same the most
fantastic piece of luck all roads lay
open journalist writer boring filmmaker
we're all arguing planning passionately
deciding as if their future depended on
no one but themselves thank you very
much
thank you so much for our next speaker
we have mr. Joseph's inter from
engineering applied science and CID so
the Center for engineering innovation
and design much like the digital
humanities lab is open to all of you and
over the last few years we've developed
a very diverse community of people
pursuing a variety of really really
interesting projects what I'd like to do
today is just show two very short videos
one demonstrates a project that was done
in collaboration with the Department of
French and the second will be a
collaboration with the Institute for the
preservation of cultural heritage
[Music]
I think what I wanted to teach the
students is the importance of close
rating why is it important to do close
reading in in a class and what does it
look to do close reading in context so
when you have this train you you're
forced to look closely at the text to
produce it in in dualist X the the train
is a metaphor because zola exaggerates
the proportion but it's also a metaphor
for progress for history for women
because the train has a women named for
sexuality and desire and also for human
bestiality I would say that the three
main metaphor or three main concept that
the train symbolizes in this text we
were looking at description in French
and in English from the text and we were
reading those description to the
engineer and they're trying to you know
a translate what we were saying into
into an object into code so we are
really reading sentences art and aiming
at translated into an object and that
was really interesting because I
remember the events were saying that all
this process is a translation Zola was
translating the images of Chinese so
when he was young
then the tech was translated in english
and then this english text was
translated into a computer program that
ended up printing a 3d train the next
example I'd like to show was one from
our course introduction to engineering
innovation and design Michelangelo's
David strong youthful standing tall
throughout the centuries but the
standing is becoming a problem over time
david has started tilting forward and so
that's creating hairline cracks in the
back of its ankles the sculpture is
probably in a couple centuries going to
fall over Michelle knows all about this
because she and her fellow students
built a way to study it in an
introductory engineering class
each group gets assigned their own
project that helps someone at Yale with
a problem that they have
Michelle's group work with Gail's
Institute for the preservation of
cultural heritage known as the IPC H
which wanted a way to study what happens
to sculptures like David over time the
students built this machine which they
nicknamed Fred and models that mimic the
angle and pressure of David's ankles
essentially our design created a machine
that applied force downward until the
models that we inserted in between these
two plates were compressed enough where
they broke david is made of marble but
the IPC H wants to study the effects of
this pressure on multiple materials so
the group also made models out of
concrete and clay it was definitely a
really good experience getting to be
hands-on so fast because it really let
me see if it was something I wanted to
do it's really satisfying to me because
see these students who when they first
showed up they maybe didn't have any
background in building things and making
things and now they're doing doing all
this great stuff as for David well for
now he's still standing tall hopefully
with the help of research like this he
can stay that way
[Music]
okay so it's just two quick projects to
demonstrate the the breadth and
diversity of the type of work that we're
doing the engineering school is so proud
of its work with the humanities that two
of its last four year lis magazines are
proudly displaying these projects so
thank you thank you for our next speaker
will have Peter Leonard from the D H lab
he'll be presenting every pixel on the
Sunset Strip Ed Ruscha between archive
and data set
terrific so first I'm really just
curious how many people in the room
raise your hand if you've heard of that
rachet before that's great that's more
than most we're really excited to talk
today about a really important pop
artist a really important collaboration
with a Getty and some interesting work
in computer vision for those who weren't
familiar with Ed rachet comes from
Nebraska comes to the west coast does
all sorts of interesting artistic work
on painting photography he's most famous
maybe for the artist book every building
on the Sunset Strip which I've put two
pictures of at the very top of the
screen and at the bottom rachet himself
looking at proofs of the book it's an
enormous complicated volume it's small
in some dimensions when you fold it out
it's really long and you can find copies
of this at Yale at least there's one in
the hasard special collection I think
there's one at the buying a key to I
really encourage you to look at every
building on the Sunset Strip it's an
artist book created out of an archive
that rachet himself built by putting a
camera in a pickup truck and driving it
down the streets of Los Angeles in the
1960s it's really kind of an early form
of Google Streetview in fact rachet
would probably claim the invented the
idea of Louisville Street View but this
is the 1960s it's black and white and he
hand he sort of carefully hand assembles
this in a completely pre-digital era
it's worth pointing out that rachet has
continued to do this work for decades
there's still vans driving around the
city of Los Angeles man by his team
putting these things together this
archive of photographs that built it was
built into collections like every
building on the Sunset Strip has
recently come to the Getty and the Getty
Research Institute put out a call for
researcher of projects to consider how
we might think of rachet and his work
not just in the context of a couple
dozen images that comprise every
building on the Sunset Strip but the
hundreds of thousands of negatives that
nobody's ever seen that go in to this
long linear visualization this kind of
banal pop art vision of the city and
when the lab applied to be one of the
teams that would work with this
collection of hundreds of thousands of
negatives we knew that we had a problem
on our hands because rachet had already
accomplished perhaps the most important
work with his photography he had created
this really important artists book and
we felt in considering an archive of
hundreds of
thousands of pictures that we really
didn't want to sort of replicate or
create a robotic version of the artists
book which already exists in all sorts
of special collections so we decided to
take a different path we wanted to think
about building a urban heat urban heat
map a sort of geospatial visualization
of discrete objects inside the
photography and what this meant is we
had to get into the world of semantic
segmentation of masking out what's
actually in each image and so I'll take
you through our process for this but the
basic notion to here is that this is a
step beyond image captioning our
cellphones can already tell us what
pictures we've taken of cats that's just
a convolutional neural network that can
provide image captions behind the scenes
they actually know what part of the
image that cat is in in your pictures if
it's at the top at the bottom a stage
beyond that towards semantic
segmentation is an example in the bottom
of this screen so we have a really
complicated image there's all sorts of
things going on here but a masking
recurrent neural network has actually
identified the bicycles as discrete from
the boy holding out his hand it's
discrete from the rider um this is done
all by sort of computational work
there's no humans involved at this phase
and so what we wanted to do is see what
this technique work on a tree shades
photography and so this is an actual
negative from the Getty Research
Institute taken by Ed rachets team in
the 60s and you can see it's the Sunset
Strip and the algorithm has expertly
identified a Volkswagen Beetle now it's
important about this is that it's never
seen a Volkswagen Beetle before right
it's been trained on much more modern
cars but the convolutional neural
network is capable of doing this masking
the semantic segmentation to tell us
exactly where the cars are and the
specific outlines not just the bounding
boxes now this is actually part of our
idea for this interface for building an
urban heat map of whether these semantic
segmented objects on it we've taken the
idea of a car just as our first demo as
you can see here what this might look
like we're looking at a map of Los
Angeles and we have kind of a way of
navigating through the city here and
looking where particular items are
you'll see that in this case our
demonstration is cars and if you look at
the very bottom of the screen you'll see
that we're actually blurring all of the
photography and only things that are
crisp are the detected cars
the bottom we created this heat map or
this sort of visualization of where
automobiles are in the map in rachets
photography but we're not trying to
replicate the artists book the interface
is inspired by the aesthetic of this
work but we really want this to be about
something else to be about discovering
the discrete objects within this archive
of hundreds of thousands of pieces of
urban photography in addition to of
finding discrete objects we want to be
able to nuance and get more specific
about what's actually in these objects
so one of the things we can do is we can
sort of begin the path down the road
towards transfer learning or retraining
neural networks to be more specific
about what they find in this image we've
retrained the final layer of a
classification network to tell us
whether a car is or is not of a looks
like an Beetle and you can see we get
really high accuracy on this this isn't
sort of cherry picked this is really
great beetle detector and that's not
actually the most important thing what
we want to do is we want to take what
we've learned about semantic
segmentation and the ability to find
objects in an archive of hundreds of
thousands of black and white negatives
and work with folks are really
interested in the urban history of Los
Angeles in the built environment we're
interested in training networks not find
cars but to find perhaps art deco and
glass brick or the red tile of Mission
Revival architecture or maybe even the
urban fabric of LA in terms of its
benches for buses its bodegas its
laundromats and stores even the
vanishing amount of single-family
bungalow houses that we're still present
in the 1960s so that's an early glimpse
into our every pixel on the Sunset Strip
rural research collaboration with the
Getty we have a brief page of
information about this on our website we
hope looked forward putting more
information online soon thanks so much
thank you very much and at last we have
philip colette and jane garrison
presenting to us
hi my name is Phil Colette I'm an
associate professor in the circuitry
department and my work focuses on how
our brains create the reality that we
perceive and I'm particularly interested
in this term here psychosis which is the
departure from consensual reality that
characterizes some serious mental
illnesses like schizophrenia so
believing things that don't pertain and
perceiving things that aren't really
there
and the way that we understand these
symptoms is sort of trade-off for
attention between what we've learned to
expect about our world through
experience perhaps captured in something
like one of those convolutional neural
networks that we just heard about and
then applying what we've learned to what
we're currently perceiving so actually
see this rotating mask of Charlie
Chaplin's face something unusual may
have happened the mask is rotating in a
clockwise direction and continues to
rotate like that however as you start to
see the inside of the face your very
strong beliefs that faces tend to be
convex
rather than concave and that light falls
onto convex rather than concave objects
in particular ways will drive you to
edit your conclusions about what you're
seeing and we think that's what we do
all of the time when we're navigating
the world we think that people who
hallucinate in their everyday lives may
do that excessively did you all see that
so it's a pretty profound I think
example of how our learning shapes what
we see and in my lab we've tried to sort
of think about ways in which
computational architectures might give
rise to that learning and how we might
model if you like hallucinations and
delusions in silico so you can imagine
that your brain is just a series of sort
of layers of neurons interacting with
one another sending predictions like
faces point outwards downwards and data
going upwards through the network and
you could think about sort of the
trade-offs between those networks in
terms of predictions that are made and
prediction errors and that the neural
machinery in your brain is really
helping you wait which thing to believe
in the case of the hollow mask you're
weighted towards you're very strong
experience in the world that faces tend
to point outwards and in my lab we try
and pick apart the neurochemical
mechanisms and neuro structural
mechanisms that give rise to these sorts
of mechanisms in order to be able to
perhaps better treat people who suffer
from delusions and hallucinations but
interestingly we can think about just in
a very simple way what might come about
if we perturb these networks so at the
lowest levels we might if we over
weighted people's beliefs at the lower
levels of the network induce very simple
basic hallucinations the sorts of things
that people experience when they take
psychedelic hallucinogenic drugs for
example and at higher doses of those
drugs or in endogenous psychotic illness
complex hallucinations might come about
when the whole network is perturbed and
you start to see new objects cut out of
whole cloth appearing before our eyes or
our ears silicon show you this video so
this is an example from some colleagues
at Sussex who have taken a Google deep
dream and returned to the lowest levels
of its network applying it now to a
video of the market place in Sussex you
can see these sort of subtle geometric
changes
so it looks sort of unusual but not
unintelligible and not entirely
unexpected it just looks sort of
low-quality
and like I said these are the geometric
patterns seem to be the sorts of things
that people experience when they take
serotonergic hallucinogens like LSD or
psilocybin just to show you now what
might happen when we make the same sort
of manipulation to the highest levels of
the network whilst looking at the same
video so now the network has been
trained on lots of different photographs
and it's inserting objects into the
video that really aren't there so you
can see jobs puffer fish eyes seem to be
fairly commonly observed so just taking
this very simple sort of network
architecture we can get some insights
into what might be happening we think in
the brains of people who are on
psychedelic drugs and in the brains of
people who have psychotic illnesses but
there's nothing in there that's really
perceiving what's sort of unusual or
uncomfortable about what you just
experienced why does it feel so uncanny
or uneasy when your brain edits the
hollow mask and causes you to see it's
switching direction and what would it
mean if that uncanny Nisour uneasiness
we're not present and so with the
digital humanities lab and also some
collaborators at C cam we've been
thinking about ways in which one might
tether two of these networks together in
what's called a generative adversarial
Network and the simple idea here is that
one side of one of these sort of
convolutional neural Nets might be
making suggestions about what's out
there in the world and another side
might be critiquing those suggestions
saying that they feel right or that they
don't feel right and and rejecting them
and that these two Nets may be training
one another and ultimately giving rise
to a sensation that actually oh yes that
feels right or that feels wrong
somehow and so that's what we've been
trying to explore these sorts of
architectures are currently being used
in the digital humanities lab for
various projects and what we're
interested in doing is partnering with
folks in digital humanities to play
around with these network architectures
break them and see the ways in which
they break see the ways in which we
might bias towards generation of
spurious information and see ways in
which we might disrupt the critic in
order to fool the generator into
believing what's out there in the world
is radically different from from reality
thank you take your order the speakers
for these amazing presentations and next
we want to make this more of a
discussion based so we're going to open
up the floor and if any I have any
questions about Andy's projects or
questions in general so I do want to
have a like a leading question just to
open up so all of this because mentioned
about the application of like
data-driven method and interdisciplinary
solutions but what do you all think is a
good disciplinary marriage in your
respective field between data arts
humanities law and what could
potentially be a bad marriage or
interdisciplinary solution well I think
something that is incredibly interesting
and thank you for your question about
that is don't going debate again that I
mention about in Chronicles about the
fact that digital humanities are a
failure because automated computing
calculation doesn't work always in the
arts and I think that the problem is
that the debate is is not shaped
correctly somehow so a bad application
of digital humanities for literature
would be to expect your the computer to
think for us simply because it doesn't I
mean automated car driving is not about
a car that is thinking it is about a car
that is reacting in every situation the
way it is
supposed to react that is very different
since in literature we especially want
to do not all but that like not to
reproduce but to seek for something else
and a good application is to use it and
I think that that goes that resonates
with all the dogs fascinating talk that
have been given there is as a new
interface as a new perception of what we
already know is it a reality is giving
access to two people by presenting
something in a different way that it is
normally and so opening the access or to
turn a book into suddenly something else
highlighting something something else in
order either to communicate on this or
to give us new clues on your way to
approach our objects so the question
makes the digital amenities relevant or
not I would say sure I'd like to add I
think I see a lot of great
interdisciplinary work I see a lot of
legal research that's being done in
conjunction with other fields for
example we have a cybersecurity course
at the Law School which is almost purely
cybersecurity with very little law
because if you're trying to make laws
about cybersecurity maybe you should
know what cybersecurity actually is
right that's just something that we lack
a little bit in law making so I think if
I think of maybe a bad interdisciplinary
project it would really just be the lack
of it I think in law and policy so you
get a lot of laws and get a lot of
policymakers who don't understand
technology or don't understand science
or don't believe in science and this
results in bad policy so that's a big
problem and I'm glad that at least you
know in universities were working
interdisciplinary work and hopefully
we'll push that forward as well not just
for a government but for industry as to
so I think an example of a bad
collaboration would be sort of falling
between two stools and not honoring this
sort of important
parties of both sides of an
interdisciplinary project sort of not
not being the best scientists and not
being the best artists in my own field I
think one of the fears is if we try and
think about mental symptoms in this way
we rob them of their deep and important
sort of heritage and meaning for people
and so I'd hate to see any approach that
we took to digitize the humanities to
forget that these sorts of experiences
these artifacts these pieces of work are
beautiful in their own right and and
what I would hope is that any
interdisciplinary work would enhance
that rather than detracting from it
are there any audience questions so when
you first like how did what inspired you
to get into this interdisciplinary field
and what inspired your like introduction
of digital methods to your field of
interest well I can say that I was
inspired by the digital humanities staff
by Peter Leonard I was preparing a
colloquium on post-war magazines
post-war cultural magazines and we just
started playing around and I I didn't
know anything about the digital
humanities except having read Franco
Moretti's book on distant reading so I
had some kind of intuition about what we
might be able to do that an individual
researcher couldn't do just going
through the pages on a microfilm I mean
like everyone else I had the nausea
effect of reading microfilm but I think
some of us are doing digital humanities
without knowing it we do look inside to
find a passage when we're preparing a
class on a book or we look at Google
books I mean it's already it's it's
already there all around us and what's
great about digital humanities
getting the culture to formalize some of
these some of these instinctive moods so
actually have part of the reason why I
started working in Interdisciplinary
sort of digital / law issues is because
that's just what I started doing during
law school I'm right now leading
initiative that's funded in part by the
Wikimedia Foundation which is a
nonprofit that runs Wikipedia and I'm
sure how many of you have used Wikipedia
pretty much everybody and I think that
having used those tools through my
education really led me to want to work
on them and work on creating world we
could support those things so one thing
I'd be really interested in knowing from
all of you actually if you don't mind me
asking one of the works topics that I
work on is the idea of open access and I
know for all of us open access
scholarship is a controversial issue you
know how can we either get our research
out there for the public either through
open access journals or through a public
scholarship whether you or not you
believe public scholarship exists or
other forms like that I'd be really
interested in hearing what you all think
about that and how we can kind of move
forward bringing a lot of this great
research at this University out there to
the public I'll try and respond so I
agree it's it's absolutely sort of
essential that we make what we work what
we work on and what we produce openly
available to the public I think what
needs to change in order to allow that
to happen is either for journals to make
that easier or for our funding bodies
and institutions to give us resources to
make that happen and I don't see either
of those things happening immediately
without us being more vocal about the
fact that that's what we want when I
write grants to the National Institute
of Mental Health for example I now build
into the budgets and funding in order to
publish my work open access it's a
different model in the UK
you can't get funding from the Wellcome
Trust or the Medical Research Council
without committing to publishing
everything that you have open access and
they're much more further along than we
are in that regard so I think you know
having conversations like this with
people like yourself and raising the
profile of that that sort of issue it is
super important and being committed to
it and enacting that commitment as much
as possible yeah maybe I would totally
agree and I would add also the way
publication basically are evaluated I'm
thinking here for instance of the
difference between publishing a critical
edition of a work in a book with a
publisher or online this has absolutely
not the same wait forever for a comedian
for a resume so maybe there it is there
is also things that could be done to
encourage the open access publication of
course open access doesn't mean
necessarily that it's not a journal but
there is something there so at this
point so what happens later what are the
ways to think about unintended
consequences of this research and
unacknowledged forebears of this
research the the surveillance state and
things like that how did these things
come into play in y'all's work can you
elaborate what you mean by the
unacknowledged or there
a lot of the some of the work comes from
entities that have used the algorithms
to detect politico acted to target ads
in bias ways things like that one
argument could be that using these in
humanistic ways is making the detour of
those algorithms I'm playing around in
that area I think it's a fascinating
question and I don't think there are any
sort of straightforward answers I think
the relationship between something like
psychology and motivation
decision-making and you know entities
like Google and Twitter and Facebook is
is tense to say that to say the least I
think the only way that we can combat
that as academics and practitioners is
to highlight what's happening and to
make these mechanisms as understandable
and and transparent for the public as
possible I don't think it would help
anyone if we turned our backs on this
and didn't study it more deeply that's
certainly how I try and handle things
with with my work which clearly you know
has all sorts of potential nefarious
implications I think that's a really
interesting question some of my research
has been on privacy law and it gets into
these issues so I have two quick things
there's one project called the all of us
program by the NIH which seeks to
collect the DNA data of a million
Americans and use that for a public
database that can then you know ideally
generate great medical advances so this
is an interesting example because here
you have clearly a well-intentioned
project that could lead to breakthroughs
in precision medicine and more but the
problem then is that people don't really
know what's happening with their DNA
data what does it mean when you give
your data to an entity that then owns
the data and can do with it what it
wants
and there's a line of legal scholarship
about a law and medicine about consent
to use of DNA samples or blood samples
and medical research for example there's
the issue of you know whether or not you
have any ownership stake in
pharmaceuticals that were developed
using research that had used samples
from certain people right so there are
these questions I think that we have to
deal with but more broadly speaking if
you're just thinking about privacy I
think there are a lot of interesting
techniques done right now to protect
privacy so that data can be used in
these large data science projects I was
reassured I was recently at a privacy
security research event at Google which
is one company that people are concerned
about obviously for privacy reasons but
they have been just really hiring a ton
of great academics for better or worse
they're taking a lot of great academics
into industry to work specifically on
privacy and security D identifying data
how to use you know federated learning
and other techniques to use the data to
find results without actually being able
to identify the data or being able to
connect the data to the data originator
so there is work being done and a lot of
it is interdisciplinary so again with
this sort of theme I think there is a
lot that could be done to help alleviate
what you're talking about
thank you for the question are there we
take about two or three more questions
this anyone have anything else to say
follow-up question on what we about so
so I think that one of the main so some
of the main purpose that why we want to
digitize things or we want to visualize
things is either to help researcher
better with their on making some of
these breakthroughs on the research but
also on the other hand being able to
present to the general public making
people understand of these some really
complicated
your project but sometimes this is
really a balance because like for
example like I grew up really scientific
American but then it presents certain
information in a way that seems
interesting but that's not necessarily
following the exact like the scientific
rigorous process I'm wondering for many
of the researchers here how do you view
that problem on digitizing or
visualizing somebody's like informations
because some of the critical information
could also lost in the digitization
process thank you for this terrific
question I think against sorry to get
back to that but yes that's one of the
big thing that digitizing is bringing it
is one of the least discussed thing you
know visitors are is our way we're on a
screen so we can do things that we
couldn't do on paper and because
probably of some cultural background the
visual is kind of the yeah it's we'll
see we'll figure out in the end how we
will show this the important is what is
behind and in fact getting on the screen
and being able to do all the things we
can do with the screen and showing
things differently I think it's one of
the major asset of any digitalization of
any kind so I work in in brain imaging
where we produce map like
representations of statistical tests
that make it appear as though parts of
the brain are lighting up or are engaged
by particular processes and they've been
whole series of papers almost cottage
industries of papers being exchanged the
seductive allure of brain images the
seductive allure of seductive allure by
the people who don't agree and I think
again it gets down to being clear
communicators telling people that these
aren't maps of recorded neural activity
but very circuitously generated
statistically massaged
visually doctored images that represent
statistical tests nevertheless but
helping people become better consumers
will be more and more important I think
as we go forward so we're seeking for
one last question from the audience
maybe if anyone has yes I'm an art
historian and I'm also the arts
information
that's a great comment I think that one
of the things that we're doing in the
lab in terms of writing reusable
software is to try to allow people to
work with cultural heritage objects
without necessarily being beholden to
their textual description in libraries
in the glam sector galleries librarians
libraries and museums archives we
oftentimes really prioritize for good
reason the textual description of visual
culture we need to have an expert look
at this and determine who the painter
was and where its provenance that's
incredibly important work the Getty does
this why CBA does this but they're also
new ways of measuring visual similarity
or arranging collections at the scale of
a hundred thousand objects based purely
on their kind of the analysis of the
raster pixels how they look and we I
think one of the things that's most
exciting to me in terms of machine
vision in terms of how computers see is
the opportunity not to break away from
human description because human
description has within it decades and
centuries really of expert provenance
and and a sort of connoisseurship but to
put that human textual description in
conversation with a kind of analysis of
the pixels themselves I think a lot of
the work if those in the room have seen
the work of the lab and Doug do
in terms of pics plot in neural
neighbors that's really exciting open
source software that we hope to see
deployed in even more cultural
institutions as an alternate way of
considering the visual without having to
do something like look for the word
horse and miss an image because it's
described as equestrian maybe you could
have like weight that kind of cuts out
some of the nuances what do you think is
can be lost
possibly and how can you protect that in
the transition in the marriage or the
synthesis between like the digital and
the humanity because as we're talking
about how the expert kind of is ruling
the kingdom and that expert is
traditionally kind of a Western white
guy and so the language that comes out
of that kind of expertise
so how my digital Yankees benefit from
kind of expanding this view of what an
expert is this was even mentioned in
earlier like how would you speak to the
need to retain the nuance as we're
transitioning I think it's a really
important question that's why I only
listen to music on vinyl to avoid any of
that quantization that will just totally
destroy the sound there's been really
interesting efforts there there's I
might miss pronounce this but mu core 2
which is an effort to build a content
management system for the glam space
which is originates more in native
understandings of knowledge or
restriction of knowledge or empowerment
of knowledge that's something that I
think a lot of folks including I just
got back from Australia where people are
really thinking about that and the in
Aboriginal context or Strait Islanders
context the great thing the wonderful
thing and the horrible thing about the
digital is that you know you can build
whatever you want with it so if you want
a system that will replicate existing
systems of knowledge control you can do
that you can also do sort of libera
Tavor or sort of transcendent approaches
that liberate information or present it
in different ways I do think it's a
fascinating question you asked about the
notion of the quantization or the
reduction I think it's a responsibility
of every humanists to say does the
particular model I'm working with
whether that's ASCII or Unicode whether
that's 8-bit color 24-bit color a vinyl
or CD does you know it's inherently
going to be a model of the of the truth
and so the question is all you know the
people think people heard a lot is all
models are wrong some of them are useful
so you as a humanist have to decide is
the model I'm working with you know that
the parallel of the Gann versus the
human sort of schizophrenia is that a
useful model you know for your
particular research question thank you
so much for this fascinating question
and if I may just a quick story because
yes quantization is breaking some
of nuances but if you add enough
information maybe you can get even more
nuance what I mean by that is I'm
working on early modern books and early
modern books are by definition hard to
find and I did my PhD in Switzerland
where they were not as much early modern
French books as in Paris so for a lot a
long time every everybody doing a PhD in
Switzerland on early modern French
literature had to work on only some
authors just because there was only
modern addition of them existing so it
was basically white males working right
when I started my PhD I was able to
access Google books so suddenly there
was a whole lot of books that weren't
available except if you were living in
Paris to me here it's all to anyone and
also a whole new lot of authors and the
texts were not only available like the
text but in a photographic reproduction
of the page so a lot of things that were
reserved to a very specific elite before
were available to the entire world
I'm putting big quotes here but we
understand what we're saying there so
suddenly a lot of new authors came into
the field and went back into the study
and IO and the this expertise of that
was previously reserved to only just a
few people that were able to access
these books on this specific in this
specific library where available and
raise new questions etc so there is this
kind of we can speak about yeah but we
don't access the actual book and it's
true and at the same time through this
quantification it's a quantization we
open the access in a very different way
so just a further comment on the ideas
of reductionism and models and that
really beautiful George box quote about
usefulness we learned a lot about how
aeroplanes can fly by making balsa wood
wings and placing them in a wind tunnel
and we never got mad at ourselves that
we couldn't cram our luggage into that
wing and take off and and leave like
we're not aiming for complete
descriptions we're aiming well
ultimately we want to come
description but our pathway there is
breaking things down and putting the
back together again
and I think that's what we're all
engaged in thank you again that's a
great question I think a lot about the
issues of knowledge equity and you know
who is considered an expert this is
something that is kind of an issue for
Wikipedia right now working on a short
strategy for the next few decades
if you've ever try to edit Wikipedia you
may have come into knowledge that it's
actually not that easy so you can try to
edit but if you for example add
something without a reference
it'll get deleted or if your reference
is deemed not expert enough or not
legitimate enough you might get deleted
as well so this is a problem because
there are whole communities around the
world that for example don't have the
same idea of expertise maybe their
knowledge is mostly oral history maybe
they don't have as many written records
as we do so it's a question for
Wikipedia right now and for I'm sure all
of us about how we look at those types
of knowledge and how we evaluate who
gets to be an expert in the room you
know who gets to sit on a panel at Yale
University talking about and what
knowledge is right I mean we don't have
anyone from those communities who may
not have the benefits of you know
multiple degrees from fancy universities
in order to talk about these things and
if they're not the conversation then
their knowledge is lost and knowledge
doesn't get to them so that's something
I think we have to think about it a lot
as well - thank you for your question
and thank you for the wonderful
responses I'd like one last applause for
our roundtable speakers
and I'd like to invite Susan Gibbons up
to give closing remarks good afternoon
everyone
I'm Susan Gibbons and I have the honor
of being Yale's university librarian and
deputy provost for collections and
scholarly communication it's also been
my pleasure to have been able to attend
these conferences this is now our fourth
and therefore can can comment on the arc
of the conference's and how they have
changed over time
initially with our first conference we
had a lot of speakers from the outside
we brought them in to help get the
conversation started today we're able to
fill the room and fill the the program
with conversations from inside of Yale
because we've come so far and there's so
many robust projects to be talked about
if you look at the program today we had
speakers who are undergraduates graduate
students faculty and librarians and I'd
say there aren't too many conferences
that happen on campus that have that mix
within that program similarly if you
look at the disciplines that were
represented math data science law French
engineering music psychiatry and many
more again where else do we have these
kinds of opportunities where we can talk
across disciplines and talk in
meaningful ways that we can actually
connect across the different disciplines
we started this conference as a way to
cause this these conversations to happen
to help share the fact that there were
common methods and tools and data
acquisition methods and methods for
demonstrating and visualizing our
findings that they were happening
throughout various disciplines but you
weren't always recognizing them and so
what we wanted this conference to do was
to give an opportunity to share ideas to
share projects and realize that you
actually have an intellectual partner
that's somewhere across this campus that
can form a network essentially to help
you move forward with your with your
projects and so I think we have done
that the last piece I'll observe though
is in our early conferences it was a
speaker presenting on a project one
after another which was wonderful but we
weren't yet
ready to have the kinds of conversations
we just have with this panel that we
could actually have the kind of
discussion that we did that goes beyond
the technology and goes beyond the
techniques and ask some of the deeper
questions that regardless of discipline
we all need to be thinking about and
that's a maturation of the conversation
here at Yale that is just so wonderful
to see an experience so we will continue
to try to bring together these these
conversations and invite even a wider
and wider audience to participate so
before we transition to our poster
session which will be right next door I
want to thank our different sponsors we
have Yale steam Yale code for good yells
digital humanities lab and the Yale
Corbeau Center for teaching and learning
throughout the day they've contributed
in many different ways and so if you
would join me in a round of applause for
our sponsors
[Applause]
[Music]